[Musique]
c'est une première pour le groupe
automobile au losange son président
directeur général en a lui même fait
l'annoncé hier le constructeur français
s'associe au château de versailles et
devient mécène catherine pégard et
olivier jose sont venus vers nous pour
nous parler cette restauration du salon
de la paix et on nous en avons parlé
avec notre président avec monsieur ghosn
qui a trouvé que c'était une excellente
idée parce que renault et le château de
versailles font partie de l'inconscient
collectif des français
on a voulu aller au-delà d'un simple
partenariat mais on a sollicité donc
renault pour un soutien plus important
est vrai mais c'est nord autour de ce
salon de la paix et je crois que carlos
ghosn a voulu cette association avec le
château de versailles puisqu'au fond
c'est parler de la création c'est parler
de l'art de vivre à la française c'est
parler des talents français derrière
cette oeuvre dolla furent eliasson tout
au bout de la guerre des des glaces se
cache le salon de la paix une
réalisation de jules hardouin mansart et
charles le brun sa dernière restauration
date des années 1950 on va nettoyer les
marmots on va nettoyer les bronzes on va
nettoyer les stucs doré et puis on va
bien entendu restaurer les peintures la
restauration des peintures a fait
l'objet déjà de danalyse très poussé et
nous savons que sous les romains du 20e
siècle et du 19e
on a à peu près 80% de l'original de
lebrun et que cette originale de le brun
va donc nous allons essayer de le
remettre à jour c'est une restauration
conservation
il ne s'agit absolument pas de
reconstituer de recréer mais de
retrouver d'être au plus près de
l'original
le groupe automobile n'a pas souhaité
communiquer sur le montant de ce mécénat
le mécénat qui permet aussi de
bénéficier de réductions fiscales pour
les entreprises
les travaux débuteront au cours de
l'année 2017 et dureront 18 mois
[Musique]
un peu plus de six mois maintenant que
les temps sont difficiles pour cette
société d'abattage de volailles
habituellement l'abattoir vend entre
1200 et 1500 volailles par semaine
aujourd'hui les ventes ont chuté à 400
pour les mauvaises semaines 800 quand
l'actualité n'évoque plus la grippe
aviaire en france pour moment il n'y a
pas de risques parce que tout est
contrôlé il ya les services sanitaires
et les services vétérinaires les
éleveurs sont que trop d fréquemment
donc je pense pas qu'il risque de s'y
côtoient
il ya une peur c'est clair il ya une
peur donc pour ça joue dessus que ça
joue sur son moral les consommateurs
depuis quelques mois deviennent plus
prudents des affichettes ont été posées
à côté de la caisse afin de les rassurer
mais beaucoup d'eux mêmes préfèrent
directement interpellé les employés
temps en temps dans entend way you lie
ce qui a pas de souci et pas de problème
chant des sirènes discussion a porté sa
peau verte
80% des transactions de cette entreprise
concerne directement le poulet un
véritable manque à gagner depuis que la
grippe aviaire fait des victimes dans le
monde depuis les vacances d'été cet
établissement à travailler seulement six
semaines pleines notamment pendant le
ramadan et les festivités de noël
le gérant s'est donc séparé de certains
collaborateurs et à peu près 50 à 60 %
de pertes depuis le mois de
septembre donc on a dû séparer de deux
employés et ce ne sont pas que les
sociétés d'abattage qui souffre déjà
certains des négociants avec lesquels il
avait l'habitude de travailler ont mis
la clé sous la porte
son entreprise est d'ailleurs en vente
même si la grippe aviaire n'est pas
forcément la raison et c'est toute la
filière qui va fermer c'est de l'aliment
jusqu'au jusqu'au consommateur quoi donc
c'est toute la filière c'est à dire les
éleveurs tout à filière
[Musique]